[Music]
all the world's a stage
and all the blah blah blah we all know
how that one goes
but if you are a theatrical type there's
a good chance you became smitten at a
very young age
[Music]
seeing the wonders of a life you might
be part of one day full of stories and
experiences you can only dream about
from the eighth row
behind two beehives in row seven
friends
[Music]
is waiting
somewhere
somewhere for me
[Music]
once smitten though then comes the work
of classes and training
of speech and technique
honing your craft as you pound the
pavement in New York City
auditioning for anything and everything
all in pursuit of that moment in the
spotlight where you hope someone might
see you really see you and say those
magic words where have you been
but what if those magic words never come
and it's only rejection over and over
again year after year and near Miss
after near Miss Until you realize that
near Miss has become your life
how do you keep at it with any hope
thank you very nice so someone's shown
up who's not on our list maybe you'll
walk in
I do know her she's capable a little
vanilla but we've got about 10 minutes
until lunch yeah sure
ready Durkin you still there yes
yes
hi oh hi I'm so sorry I thought my agent
assured me that I was on the list do you
have the pages for the role of the nanny
uh yes is it just the one scene that's
right whenever you're ready
enough
enough of your questions Detective
I'm happy to tell you who I am and what
it is I do without your insistent
probing
I am a caretaker of children
to whom I'm given charge
am I a substitute for the child's True
Mother
some would prefer I say no but I believe
I am
I must be
their mother when it's only me with them
because
child needs to feel at all times safe
they need to feel protected with the
kind of ferocity only a mother can
summon
it's no matter if they were born of my
own
flesh
would I kill
to protect a child in my charge
that is the question you have for me I
assume Detective
[Music]
that I would say without so much as
blinking I would kill without
compunction
sake and safety of any child in my care
ER so
now you have your answer
where have you been
[Music]
um
but when you finally do land your dream
your moment in that Spotlight I said
where have you been
oh how far would you go to hang on to it
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]